SpaceX is getting closer to going to Mars
as it tests out prototypes of its gigantic
Starship nearly every month.
The aim is to fly an uncrewed mission to the
red planet as early as 2024.
CEO Elon Musk has said he’s fairly confident
people will land on Mars in 2026.
That’s just two years after NASA’s goal
of sending astronauts back to the moon which
is itself a very ambitious timeline.
If and when Starship takes off with travelers
aboard, it won’t just be a trip for those
with money but those with guts.
It's dangerous, it's uncomfortable.
Going to Mars reads like that ad for Shackleton going to the Antarctic.
That’s a reference to the famed Anglo-Irish
explorer Ernest Shackleton, who is said to
have put out this ad in a newspaper to recruit
brave souls to brave the bitter Antarctic
cold.
Just as the conditions of Antarctica are difficult
and dangerous, the Martian environment won’t
exactly be hospitable.
Honestly, a bunch of people probably will
die in the beginning.
It’s tough sledding over there.
He believes the tough sledding is worth
trying to colonize Mars in case he says anything
were to happen to planet Earth.
Before we talk about the challenges of living
on Mars, it will be tough enough just to get there.
25 out of the 49 robotic missions to Mars
have failed to get to the fourth planet from
the Sun.
The journey will take six months or longer.
The optimal time to go is when the distance
between the Earth and Mars is shortest.
That’s once every two years or so.
Even then, it’s still going to be a 34-mile
or 55 million km trek.
The traveling distance will actually be even
greater because it can’t be done in a straight line.
So the trajectory will be similar
to a quarterback throwing a football.
They don’t throw the ball to where the receiver
is at any given moment  but where the teammate
will be in the future as they continue to
run down the field.
Course corrections will be necessary.
If it isn’t done with precision, the spacecraft
could get lost in space or crash when it reaches
its destination.
It has happened already.
In 1998, a software issue sent NASA’s Mars
Climate Orbiter too close to the red planet
and it was either destroyed in the atmosphere
or got lost orbiting the sun.
Live communication won’t be possible either
because it takes as long as 24 minutes for
radio signals to travel back to Earth.
So the spacecraft is on its own, dependent
on an onboard computer to automate the entire
procedure.
Those minutes will feel like hours.
And once it prepares to land, the vehicle
- this one simulating Starship - will perform
a complex landing maneuver.
If getting safely to Mars is going to be difficult,
living there will be an even greater challenge.
NASA’s Perseverance rover that touched down
in February has been studying the habitability
of Mars and looking for signs of past microbial
life.
Its cameras captured NASA’s Ingenuity helicopter
flying in the dusty, desert world.
Gigantic dust storms, resembling tornadoes,
can cover the entire planet and the dust is
toxic.
Many people often assume Mars is hot but because
it’s farther from the sun and has an atmosphere
100 times thinner than Earth’s, there are
huge temperature swings.
A daytime high of 22° Celsius or 71° Fahrenheit
on the surface could drop to -99° Celsius
or minus 146° Fahrenheit at night.
That thin atmosphere would also expose aspiring
Martians to radiation.
And Mars has no magnetic field to deflect
these deadly rays and particles unlike the
magnetic bubble that protects Earth.
Building homes underground would offer protection
- or possibly building them above ground with
a protective layer of regolith - loose deposits
of dust and broken rocks.
There’s no shortage of that on the red planet.
And if you step outside without a spacesuit,
the low atmospheric pressure would cause
your blood to boil.
A NASA scientist has compared it to popping
a can of soda.
You’d fizz to death.
The atmosphere is primarily carbon dioxide
so the failure of a spacesuit is a potential
death sentence.
To get around this problem, NASA is experimenting
with trying to convert CO2 into oxygen with
a toaster-sized instrument aboard the Perseverance
rover called MOXIE.
That could one day provide breathable air
and could also help lift rockets off the planet’s
surface since propellant depends on oxygen.
And of course, the big challenge of living
on Mars is figuring out how to get safe drinking
water.
There are small quantities of water in the
soil and as vapor in the atmosphere, but most
of it exists as ice.
Perhaps the most viable option for the first
humans on Mars is to live on their spaceship
at first, using it as a habitable base for
the building of a city.
There’s been talk of terraforming
Mars - engineering it to make it more Earth-like
by creating enough oxygen so that humans can
breathe.
However, that’s a long way off from the
near-term goal of first-time travelers which
is simply to survive the night.
It's dangerous, it's uncomfortable, it's a
long journey.
You might not come back alive.
But it's a glorious adventure, and it'll be
an amazing experience. And your name will go in history.
Yes. You might die.
If you’re considering whether to book that
ticket to Mars and can’t decide, you can
learn more about the red planet by watching
space documentaries.
But for explorers and dreamers, the red planet
is warm and inviting.
I’ve been enjoying this episode of A Curious
World available on CuriosityStream which sponsored
this video.
CuriosityStream is brought to you by the founder
of the Discovery Channel.
I have a whole list of documentaries
to get through on space, science, tech, and history.
To sign up, head to curiositystream.com/newsthink. The link is in my description.
The price of a membership is only $15 for
the entire year.
Not month, but year.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.